[Music]
now play some Mexican music hey relax do
you have a leash somewhere here we go
the more he moves the more powerful he
becomes okay hey guys what we're doing
is we're blocking him from becoming
powerful just by movie hmm if he moves
he gets excited if he doesn't move he
gets calm hmm then when he's calm then
you play they get done eventually what
happens is the sound of the guitar
creates relaxation hmm earlier seconds
ago the sounds of the guitar create
excitement okay
[Music]
so we send them to another position this
is the calm submissive state that I keep
telling you about right the reason why
your correction didn't work yeah because
you look yeah there was just tension he
wanted upfront it is I just want that
okay
instead in this all right see that yeah
that's tension yeah this snaps you out
of it okay so when he's getting into
that state you just want to snap him out
of it that's the intention but you have
to have it and your mind not just the
body right you know because what he's
reading is the energy not the body he
knows I'm not totally into it exactly
right lady now it's Veronique Stern to
try and influence noopy with her energy
I like that that's touring that the
leash that's what stay there accomplish
[Music]
down secant should be sensitive to this
one Japan yes he's not damn knows not he
is not taking her serious right right
simple as that simple is it do we have
her try to play the guitar and let me
try to determine see try it try it
alright also like a team yeah let's say
so let's see no good good keep on keep
on
[Music]
don't worry about it so I was working
one human was very draining to me that
was Veronique really to get her to get
her into the state of being calm and
assertive took a lot of me know under
was very cooperative about becoming and
listening and given you know how he
feels and sharing and pouring himself
out my torch is serious my touch is
serious is to the point what I want is
for you to enjoy her playing a guitar
gonna be sleeping right right when
Andrew and and Veronique decide to work
as a team they created a powerful
positive energy and they were able to
accomplish the behavior that they want
your birthday they're gonna play for you
okay and you have to do this
[Music]